hey guys Pete here this is the second
installment of my twin peak season one
rewatch this is brought to you by my
patrons over on patreon before I jump
into this just a reminder I am having a
book giveaway over there on patreon so
there'll be a link here that you can
follow or you could check it out in the
endcard of the video giving away the
final dossier which is only two weeks
away now and that's pretty exciting so
depending on how you count the pilot I
mean obviously this is the second
episode in season one or Twin Peaks
there's no doubt about that there was
the pilot and then this one for some
reason they count the pilot as not a
number or number zero and they call this
episode 1 of season 1 but that's really
complicated so I'm gonna call this
season 1 episode 2 it has a made-up name
that no one really knows where it came
from and that is traces to nowhere and
it originally was on TV on the 12th of
April in 1990 just as I did with the
first one the pilot I'm going to go over
the log ladies intro first and for this
episode she said I carry a log yes is it
funny to you it's not to me behind all
things are reasons reasons can even
explain the absurd do we have time to
learn the reasons behind human beings
varied behavior I think not some take
the time are they called detectives
watch and see what life teaches so this
episode is pretty solid all the way
around it's not quite as good as the
pilot for me but there's really nothing
wrong with it either when I think about
the context of when it came out it must
have been equally as confusing as the
pilot because it opens with one of my
favorite openings which is agent Cooper
hanging from a pipe in his room at the
Great Northern he's hanging upside down
and talking into his tape recorder to
Diane and that really just was funny to
me when I first saw it and it continues
to be to this day but I mean overall
this isn't a funny episode there's a
couple other famously funny parts like
the fish in the percolator but for the
most
it's character-building you know we
talked about everything revolving around
Laura's murder in the first episode and
how it affected people in this episode
we get to learn a little bit more about
those people in general unrelated to
Laura and their connection to Laura
of course Laura's murder still on
everyone's mind and the investigation is
just picking up and one of the things
that I realized whenever I watched it
this time that maybe I never noticed
before and it might have something to do
with season three is that these episodes
are pretty much one day a piece and I
looked into that and I found out that
that is the case throughout the entire
two seasons so that's pretty interesting
to think about that each one is one day
so the whole series would be about a
month and if you think about everything
that happens in it that's a lot of stuff
that's a busy month this episode was
written by Mark Frost and David Lynch
but it was directed by Duane Dunham he
edited the pilot and he was also the
editor on blue velvet and wild at heart
of course wild at heart was being worked
on at the same time a season one he was
handed the reins and he was supposed to
make it just about the same as the pilot
and overall it came out pretty good I
don't think you could be confused that
it was done by Lynch but I think it was
pretty consistent I don't think there
was anything that would have seemed off
especially at the time when people were
first getting to know these characters
as I mentioned we opened up in room 315
in Dale Cooper's room at the Great
Northern we're gonna be there a lot more
this is the first time that we saw a
couple interesting things here that he
brings up he it was the first thing that
he said about the Marilyn Monroe and the
Kennedy family he brings out that idea
of who really pulled the trigger even
now that still seems kind of out of
place but it may be a hint that he's
already under the effect of his new
location here in Twin Peaks and the
other thing is that we get the delivery
of the iconic line Dale Cooper after
trying the coffee over at the Great
Northern says you know this is excuse me
a damn fine cup of coffee and that's
been a catchphrase for the last 27 years
or so I really can't say for sure
but this may be like that those those
two actual things that I just mentioned
the hanging from the pipe and the damn
fine cup of coffee that may really be
where Dale Cooper is born in this you
know in the beginning we feel like he's
pretty straight-laced I mean there's
some interesting stuff going on in the
pilot but here he kind of hits his
stride for being a very compelling
character we do see Audrey Horne come in
and flirt with him there's really no
doubt about it she's pretty forward but
even though he doesn't really react we
kind of I kind of thought this time when
I losted that we learned that she's
really not a bad girl
a bad person I mean she's a teenager
here she's a high schooler she does some
goofy things you know there's what's the
norwegians and some of these other
things that we see her doing but there's
really nothing about her being a
dangerous character or a suspicious
character she's just a young girl who's
growing up we get a little bit of funny
footage of donuts everybody chewing
Donuts sheriff Truman sits there and
chews on one where he can't even talk as
Cooper's running down the list of all
the things are gonna do that day at the
sheriff's office we get a little bit
more doc Hayward
he's noticeably and visibly affected by
this post-mortem he had to call in
someone else to help and he just
assisted we could tell that you know
they're very close he mentions that his
daughter Donna was her best friend
we find out that Laura had been with
three men at least the night of her
deaths and that they were not Bobby or
James those two are both locked up in
the basement at this point we realized
that there's some tension going on
because they had some money that they
owed Leo that is in or was in a safety
deposit box we've actually seen the
money but we didn't know what the deal
was
they're out ten grand and they owe it to
Leo who has showed himself to not be a
very cool character one thing that stood
out here about Leo was they really
painted him as the fall guy
right away I mean it's going back and
watching at other times you know I
new who killed Laura Palmer so either
way they really kind of lay it on sick
with Leo's blood-stained shirt and then
showing him with the soap and the sock
and the that incident I mean luckily
they didn't show that on screen but we
can tell pretty clearly by Shelly's fear
and the way that she slumps onto the
floor right away that this is not
something new
leo has done this sort of thing before
and basically Shelly is a hostage in
this relationship we find out that
Cooper had one thing that he wasn't sure
about when it came to James and he found
that out by interviewing him we see
James is honest and he explains what was
going on in Laura's life leading up to
that night Cooper's satisfied that he's
not the killer the broken heart pendant
is brought up again we saw that they hit
it James and Donna hit it out in the
woods but some unknown person had come
back and dug it up we know it's not the
police that have it at this point
outside of the police station we see
Donna explain to her mother what's going
on how she fell in love with James and
James fell in love with her we see that
there's real conflict for her because
she's really sad that her friend died
but at the same time she's really happy
that this relationship is blossoming
with James this is the episode that
really sets the stage for the nighttime
soap opera angle I guess because
everything was so closely tied into
Laura's murder in the first episode this
episode really opens things up a little
bit more and it's really kind of a good
scene it's one of my favorite Donna
scenes I guess you could say because it
does give a good compelling reason for
some of the stuff that happens with her
throughout the series we do see coop and
harry s truman go visit Josie Packard to
go to question her because Laura was her
English teacher or her English tutor I
guess might be the correct way to
describe that and they wanted to know if
there was anything unusual or out of
place that happened on the day she died
the scene basically gives us an idea of
how observant Cooper is and it I think
it's mostly there for that reason we see
that he figures out through body
language
that Harry and Josie have a thing going
and obviously it's really funny because
of the fish in the percolator deal that
happens with Pete Martell that's still
an ongoing mystery as far as I know
no one really knows where that fish came
from but watching Cooper's face after he
finds out that it was there is hilarious
that sort of gets us right into this
deal with Kathryn we see her call Josie
up and then we see that she's in cahoots
with Benjamin Horne it lays the
groundwork that there's a plan going on
Kathryn definitely seems gung-ho to push
on what's the fact that they don't think
Josie's gonna sell so they're gonna have
to force their hand there's a bit of a
heart-wrenching scene whenever Donna
goes to visit Sarah Palmer it's a really
unbelievable moment here and it's hard
to watch I mean I think that every
single time I see it and both actresses
do really well and that's what I always
come away with I think is that you kind
of feel for both of them because it's
just sort of like what would you do if
you were in Donna's place there you know
what I mean it's kind of a bad special
effect there where they show Laura's
face on Donna but you know this was the
early 90s so what are you gonna do it's
also the first time that we see Bob in a
vision I guess at that point we don't
know who Bob is but we see a menacing
character at the foot of the bed and we
see Sarah Palmer scream deputy Hawk is
over at the hospital and he is
interviewing the parents of brunette
Pulaski we find out runit is a salesgirl
over at Benjamin horns department store
she works at the perfume counter and
Hawk also sees the one-armed man coming
out of the elevator and going around
towards the morgue but he basically
disappears a little bit more odd
reaction Ben gets pissed off at her
because she's playing music loud in his
office she fesses up for what she did
with the norwegians and we see that it's
just sort of an ongoing kind of thing
going between those two really intense
scene with major Garland Briggs and
Bobby
before Briggs kind of grows on you so
you're like what's up with this guy kind
of you know what I mean he's definitely
by the book all the way I mean what he
says is pretty well thought out and apt
but it goes in one ear and out the other
with Bobby and he slaps him eventually
because he's got a cigarette in his
mouth and it's a pretty good primer for
how that relationship is going
even though Bobby doesn't want to hear
it we can see that major Briggs has
strong feelings for his son the double
arc comes into the equation as coupe and
Truman go there Cooper gets to try the
Cherry Pie finally and after one bite he
wants to order two more pieces and he
meets the Lord lady
formally but he won't ask her Logue a
question so she kind of storms off after
saying that log saw something and
someday he'll want to talk to it we also
find out in this short scene that Laura
was doing meals on wheels as well she
actually even started the program so she
was involved with a lot of different
things we've heard that she is tutoring
Josie working with Johnny horn he's 27
and in the third grade but at the same
time while she's doing these meals on
wheels she's also dating Bobby and doing
coke and hiding the money at her thing
so she's obviously involved so we're
seeing that she's a very complicated
character I've already mentioned the
scene with Leo and Shelley gets home
after that happens we see dr. Lawrence
Jacobi who started off pretty
interesting in the pilot episode but I
think when we see him here at home he
crosses over into the super weird zone
and we see that he's very eccentric he
has this sort of Hawaiian thing going on
like a Hawaiian theme he pops in a tape
to the tape deck puts on his headphones
and we hear that it's Laura talking into
a tape recorder we hear say about
getting lost in the woods again she
mentions a mystery
and says James is sweet but so dumb
and we find out that Jacobi is the one
who stole the half-heart necklace that
James and Donna had buried and that he
has it hidden in a coconut in his office
we see him holding it and he's crying
and really we don't know why he's crying
at this point is he crying because he's
guilty is he crying because he knows
something more or is he just crying
because he misses Laura because he
obviously if he has these tapes and
whatnot that he had some kind of
extracurricular kind of relationship
going on so a lot of you mentioned that
you like the extra facts so I looked
through to see what else I could find
out about this I mentioned earlier that
they do represent a day I guess if we
think about fire walk with me and we add
that into there that was seven days and
then we have all of the episodes of the
series so yeah it's about a month long I
found out through my research that the
Marilyn Monroe reference wasn't 100%
random mark frost and David Lynch
collaborated first together on a movie
about Marilyn Monroe that was called
goddess and never actually got made but
there is a kind of a Twin Peaks
connection when you think about that is
you know Laura was a blonde and she died
under mysterious circumstances much in
the same way that Marilyn Monroe did and
they were both very complicated
characters this is the first episode
that was shot on sound stages the pilot
was set on you know those are all shot
in locations I guess from what I
understand so whenever they built these
stages they made them look most pretty
much like the originals but there's a
scene here that I noticed because the
guys just welding you know he's just
there's no nobody's wearing masks and
he's just sort of standing there
watching him welding and that's actually
thrown in there because there's no
double doors in the soundstage so when
we look at the Sheriff's Department in
the pilot there's opening there's double
doors that open and I guess for
continuity they had this welding scene
because it kind of shows
that they're taking the doorway apart
that's pretty interesting one of the
things that stands out every time when I
watch this and I don't know if you
noticed it or not but I was just making
another twin peaks' video earlier and I
used the image of Audrey sticking the
pencil in the cup at the end of that one
where she has her pilot hair and I you
know I realized when I was watching this
episode how her hair in one night grew
into this really nice-looking haircut
which is probably an improvement I think
over the short hair that she had in the
pilot but either way it's kind of funny
when you think about it that in one day
her hair went from being short to about
shoulder lane I had mentioned Duane
Dunham earlier I did not know that he
was the assistant editor on the Empire
Strikes Back as well as the editor on
Return of the Jedi I also found out in
this research the David Lynch was asked
to direct Return of the Jedi that would
have been an interesting thing to see I
would say but yeah Dunham's he has
worked on things up into this you know
he's still involved with the Twin Peaks
universe he was an editor again on
season three he's credited for all 18
episodes on IMDB and that's about any
that I can find out about special
information about the episode and like I
said in the beginning I mean I think
it's a really good episode it's just not
quite as good as the pilot it goes in a
different direction which it needs to do
and there's really nothing wrong about
it I mean I like that I like the Cooper
that we meet here I like how that
develops the major garland brig stuff is
interesting when you rewatch you know
you really see how they pepper these
characters in there and how they're
important right from the beginning but
you're so focused in on Laura herself
and the characters that were closest to
her that you kind of overlook them
obviously like I mentioned the scene
where Sarah Palmer and Donna are
together is a highlight also Donna's
scene with her own mother is very
interesting mark frost dad Warren Frost
had a great performance there in the
scene where he's talking about the post
mortem and we get to know everybody a
little bit better
thought it was pretty good but I'm
interested to see what you guys think
it's kind of hard to say objectively
when I have such favorite episodes that
I know that are coming up and whatnot so
on a rewatch I'd say it's good not the
best but definitely in the upper echelon
of episodes let me know what you guys
think I should have a new video in this
series next week so let me know how
you'd like to see things go I have been
toying with the idea of doing a live
stream maybe doing that like in a Q&A so
we can discuss the episode together so
give me a chime in on that as well
please like the video if you enjoyed it
if you'd like to try to win the final
dossier by mark frost which comes out
October 31st follow the link to my
patreon account and read all about the
giveaway there you can also get involved
with helping to keep this video series
alive I want to thank everyone who has
gone there and signed up I really
appreciate it I'm enjoying making this
series and it's all because of you guys
make sure you subscribe to my channel
turn on notifications after that follow
me on my social media accounts and
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon